- So, were you familiar,
'cause you're so young,
and "Karate Kid" was like,
more when I was a little kid,
so were you familiar
with "The Karate Kid"?
- [Mary] I was not.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh,
what were you thinking, then,
when you went in the audition?
- [Mary] I actually accidentally
slept through my initial audition.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
(all laughing)
And she still got the job! You're amazing!
I don't tell them that!
I don't know what excuse
my agents came up with,
but I realized I slept through it.
My boyfriend called me and he was like,
"Hey, so how'd your audition go?"
And I was like, "What audition?"
And he was like, "The one you had today!"
And I was like, "Oh, crap!"
And he was like, "What was it even for?"
And I was like, "Oh, it's
this show called 'Cobra Kai,'"
and he's a huge "Karate Kid" fan,
so he was like, "What? Are you kidding me?
Like, I've been in a group chat
about this show coming out
for like, three months.
Like, are you serious?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
He was like, "Get your butt back in there!
Whatever you gotta do, call
whoever you got to call,
like, get your butt back in there,"
And by some miracle,
they let me come back,
so I got to go in for my next audition,
and he was like, "We
should watch the movies!"
And I was like, "Uh, no." (laughs)
- [Kelly] What?! They're so awesome!
- [Mary] I know, but I didn't wanna,
- Do you know how long
I did the crane move?
Like, trying to do the kick
like it was a real thing.
(laughs)
So, Mary, how did you get into acting?
- I kind of, like, stumbled
into it by happy accident.
I was five years old
and my mom had a friend
who lived in Pennsylvania.
We were still in Pine Bluff,
Arkansas, it's where I'm from,
and she was like,
"Hey, you guys are coming for
the summer anyway, to visit.
They're doing this open casting call.
I just got my son into acting.
Your kids would have a ball!
They're looking for a five-year-old girl
and your daughter's five!"
And my mom came to us and she was like,
"You wanna go for an audition?"
And I literally had like,
every finger painted
a different rainbow color,
my hair was wet with chlorine,
and it was like, "Yeah,
sure! Let's do an audition."
I don't know what it was.
So, I went and auditioned
and I ended up being the photo double
for Abigail Breslin and the movie "Signs"
when I was five.
- What?!
That's amazing!
- I had no idea the difference, either,
so, I mean, to me, I
got to hang out on set,
- To you, you're the lead.
- Oh, yeah!
I was having a great time.
Like, Joaquin Phoenix taught
me how to do the, this thing,
So I would just walk
around doing this all day.
I got chicken nuggets from craft services,
like, I was having the time of my life!
- [Kelly] That's amazing!
And what a random, like, turn of events!
- [Mary] Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah, totally.